el dólar sigue por las nubes mientras el
mundo intenta ajustarse a la alta
inflación animada entre otras cosas por
la Guerra de Ucrania la volatilidad
desde la divisa continuará hasta el
próximo año afectando los bolsillos de
la ciudadanía y con graves impactos en
América Latina vamos al análisis de este
tema y para ello nos acompaña José Luis
de la Cruz el ese director general de
del instituto para el desarrollo
industrial y del crecimiento económico
bienvenido Gracias por estar con
nosotros y sabemos que en el
fortalecimiento del dólar está
relacionado con la lucha contra la
inflación que emprenden los bancos
centrales del mundo subiendo los tipos
de interés tomando en cuenta que el
dólar es la moneda referente en el
planeta según un estudio del fondo
monetario internacional el 40% de las
transacciones mundiales son en dólares
sin importar se involucran a Estados
Unidos Aquí le pregunto yo esto es bueno
para Estados Unidos pero malo para el
resto de los países y sus Divisas Y por
qué
Bueno yo creo que ya tenemos como
referencia un elemento que ocurrió en la
década de los 80s del siglo pasado en
donde el aumento en las tasas de interés
por parte de la reserva federal y En
aquel momento del Banco Central de
Inglaterra ocasionaron una o agravaron
una recesión en América Latina por
ejemplo y en este sentido las cosas no
han cambiado mucho por el contrario la
globalización en la integración
financiera han permitido que algunos de
estos efectos se transmitan de manera
más rápida en ese aspecto el que
tengamos incrementos sucesivos y una
perspectiva de que la política monetaria
de Estados Unidos se va a mantener
rígida es decir que van a seguir
intentando controlar la inflación y
evitando que las burbujas financieras
que se formaron en todo el mundo y
particularmente en su mercado sigan
creciendo Pues básicamente lo que nos
genera es una expectativa que para
América Latina y en general para el
resto del el mundo esos efectos van a
seguir presentes y los bancos centrales
de cada país tendrán también que seguir
endureciendo su política monetaria mire
teniendo en cuenta que el resto de
bancos centrales del mundo también están
subiendo los tipos de interés más allá
de la fortaleza del dólar esta crisis
dejó al descubierto La debilidad del
resto de las monedas O podría mencionar
casos como el yen japoneses que ha caído
Pues a las intervenciones del Banco
Central el euro y la libra Usted qué
opina
Bueno yo creo que lo que estamos
observando es que en épocas de
incertidumbre El dólar y la economía de
Estados Unidos sigue viéndose como una
reserva de valor es decir con un lugar a
donde sobre todo las inversiones más
especulativas tienden a refugiarse muy
rápidamente en segunda instancia
coincido con su punto de vista al final
del día también esto muestra que otras
economías que tradicionalmente también
han sido Refugio de valor Durante los
últimas las últimas décadas la Unión
Europea Japón También en estos momentos
por sus características particulares
particularmente en Europa por la
expectativa de una recesión y de
restricciones muy importantes en materia
energética por el problema en Ucrania
pues dejan de ese tener esa
característica que les había distinguido
Durante los últimos lustros y al final
del día los capitales salen de allá
porque ven que hay alta volatilidad
incertidumbre perspectivas de que la
economía no va aprovechar bien Y
entonces están yendo a Estados Unidos y
en algún momento a algunas economías
emergentes que están ofreciendo altos
intereses en estos momentos en donde los
mercados financieros no lo están
haciendo no están ofreciendo grandes
rendimientos muy bien José Luis se une a
nuestra entrevista o Jorge Hurtado que
es el periodista llamado hablar de
economía en el canal y pues Jorge Siga
usted por favor con sus preguntas Buen
día José Luis bueno básicamente le
quería preguntar sobre en el contexto
del g20 que se va a realizar
sabemos que la fortaleza del dólar
afecta el tema de la deuda para muchos
países sobre todo y en el caso
particular de América Latina puedo
mencionar el caso de Argentina y su
debuta con el fondo monetario
internacional el dólar fuerte estaría
agravando esta crisis de deuda para los
países y qué alternativa tienen
Bueno yo creo que ahorita tenemos que
analizar la situación que se vive a
nivel global y particularmente en
América Latina en Casos de Argentina con
la fortaleza del dólar efectivamente
pero también teniendo en consideración
que eso está muy vinculado A cómo se
está moviendo las tasas de interés y que
al final de cuentas también tiene que
ver con la situación económica
particular de comercio exterior por
ejemplo es decir cómo está la balanza
comercial La balanza de cuenta corriente
de todas estas naciones y de todas estas
regiones del mundo y entonces
efectivamente lo que vamos a estar
observando Es que este dólar fuerte lo
que está reflejando es la debilidad que
existe de forma sistémica en la economía
global como algunas zonas son percibidas
con mayor riesgo como las economías que
están enfrentando alta inflación pues
evidentemente lo que tienen lo que están
enfrentando son expectativas de que la
política monetaria se va a endurecer más
y esto Qué significa que al final del
día lo que veremos es de que
la economía se va a frenar esto implica
posibilidades de recesión En aquellos
país que evidentemente
ahuyentan a los capitales fortalecen al
Dólar y de alguna manera también pues
esto implica una mayor debilidad de
ciertas economías y de ciertas monedas y
en este contexto José Luis en los
últimos meses hemos visto una
volatilidad sobre todo en las monedas de
países como Colombia chile y Argentina
esta situación podría continuar en los
próximos meses tomando en cuenta que la
mayoría de organismos y analistas preven
estas desaceleración que usted
mencionaba y también que la Fed Va a
continuar evidentemente subiendo sus
tipos de interés
Bueno yo creo que hay tres aspectos
esenciales aquí uno es el mundo está
viviendo un cambio estructural a qué me
refiero con esto mucho de los beneficios
que recibieron los países en América del
Sur
estaban atribuidos en el corto plazo a
un muy buen desempeño que tuvieron los
precios de las famosas materias primas
de los commodities eso permitió una
entrada importante de capitales que en
algunos casos ocasionó una apreciación
de una de sus monedas pero en estos
momentos en donde hay una desaceleración
en donde el precio de los comités viene
a la Baja pues evidentemente eso está
llevando al lado opuesto la evolución de
las monedas en segunda instancia es de
que los principales socios comerciales
de algunas de las naciones de América
del Sur son o la Unión Europea
particularmente por ejemplo en el caso
de Brasil por ejemplo Alemania o también
países asiáticos que están viviendo una
reconfiguración de su economía por
ejemplo el caso de Japón mencionaba al
inicio eso también está afectando la
perspectiva y en tercera instancia la
evolución interna de la economía en
donde lo que se está previendo es de que
exista en algunos casos desaceleración
en algunos como en el caso de chile una
posible recesión y entonces eso desde mi
punto de vista va a mantenerse en el
futuro junto con lo que ya también
platicábamos el hecho de que a nivel
global la perspectiva sobre la reserva
Federal es de que va a mantener una
política monetaria muy dura muy bien
entonces Cuáles son los sectores que sí
se benefician por la subida del dólar en
América Latina
Bueno yo creo que esta es una
oportunidad para el fortalecimiento de
las exportaciones es decir En aquellos
países en donde se tenga una capacidad
de exportadora y ya no nada más de
materias primas sino de sectores de
mayor valor agregado en donde la
manufactura es evidentemente la columna
vertebral hoy por eso la mayor parte del
mundo está aplicando estrategias muy
Audaces de política industrial y
hablamos desde Europa hablamos del este
de asia y también en la propia América
Latina Entonces yo creo que es el
momento en donde se puede de reimpulsar
la exportación de una variedad de
productos altamente industrializados
Cuáles pueden ser estos maquinaria
equipo equipo eléctrico electrónico y
las propios textiles pero ya con mayor
capacidad transformadora en segunda
instancia me parece que esto va a
llevarnos a una regionalización es decir
a buscar oportunidades
más cerca de cada país y evidentemente
el mercado interno es decir cuando
nuestra moneda pierde fuerza frente al
Dólar sale más caro importar Y entonces
eso lo que debe de estar promoviendo es
fortalecer la capacidad productiva para
atender las necesidades del mercado
interno a menores costos que lo que
implica importar con un Dólar más caro